وانا عارف اني هزعلها الناس
هتذبح واللي يسال يسال جده
بالنظريه وبالعلم
اكثر المدن السعوديه حيويه واكثر المدن
السعوديه قابليه انها تصل الى تطلب
[موسيقى]
الرؤيه ان تكون في ثلاثه مدن ضمن القائمه
الميته جده اقربهم واقل لهم تكلفه للوصول
واللي يقول جده ما تستطيع
طب خلينا ناخذ لهذه لان هذا الموضوع
الله شاهد
الحين انت انت الان دخلتنا في فحو الامر
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح صحيح في فنجان حلقات متعدده عن
تصميم المدينه
الحلقه تنتهي بالحديث عن تصميم وهندسه
الحرم المكي وليه مثلا تصميم الحرم المكي
لم يراعي الهويه المكيه في بناء وكيف صمم
المطاف والساحات لكن كيف نقدر نناقش كل
هذه الافكار والنقدات على تصميم نحتاج
اننا نتكلم مع المصمم للحرب ونفهم كيف
يفكر طريقه تفكيره في العماره والتصميم
الحضري للمدينه تعطينا فهمنا طريقه كيف
صمم الحرم بهذه الطريقه
الدكتور عبد الله بن جنيد يقول ان العماره
هدف هلا اساسي والصناعه الدهشه وان
تدخل التوسعه الثالثه الا وتصاب بالدهشه
في كل جزء منها لكن ما نقدر نتكلم عن
الحرم بمعزل عن مكه والمجتمع مكه هل
استطاع الحرم توظيف مجتمع مكه في تصميمه
وماذا عن الزائر والمعتمر تبدا رحلته
اليوم من المطار الى القطار الى الفندق في
الحرم ويعود الى المطار بعدين يرجع مدينته
هل التصميم للمدينه يراعي احتكاك الزوار
مع اهل مكه لان نخرج من مكه ونروح الى جده
ابو يزيد يعيش في جده ويحبها يقول ان جده
اكثر مدينه سعوديه حيويه وان انا قادرين
على اعاده الحياه الكثير من اجزائها
التنكيد على السياره
قبل ان نبدا
شاركونا اسماء ضيوف او مواضيع تقترحونها
على فنجان هذه دائما تساعدنا في الوصول
الى اسماء رائعه
راسلنا على بريد البرنامج فنجان الثمانيه
دوت كوم
وحنا الوحيدين من ضمن القبيله كلهم
عشره يجي
بعجاني يزيد وقلت ابو سميه جنيدب يصير
اسمه جنيد بن جنيدر تفضل
يا اخي انا
قال اخوي خالد خلاص ابشر ابشر وكل حاجه
وخلاص
واخوي وسجل يزيد
وارسل له الاسم ولا مسجل ليش
مسجل
دائما هيا هيا هيا ابويا اخوها وجدي اخوها
لازم البنت الاولى اسمها
هيا قالت اختي هيا الله يرحمها توفت قالت
اختي والله ما تسمياها يا بنت الحلال
تطلع تريد
وقلت ابغى اسم لانه يزيد اسم ممنوع من
الصرف لانه فعلا
اسم ممنوع من الصرف لانه فعل وبحرف الياء
وانحشرت في يزيد يمين
سبحان الله وانا اقرا لي كنت اقرا في
القران
كويس
نظرات كل الاشياء الناس تشوفها بطريقه
مختلفه هو ما في صح ولا غلط هي
استيعاب الانسان لشيء ما انت تستوعبه
بطريقه وهو يستوعب بطريقه
انه انا عايش عندي عناد وباسم جدي وانا
اروح راح يزيد صار اسمي يزيد
سجله
يا اهلا وسهلا
ههه بدون ما يطلع قال ههه فهي مهتمه وهي
ما يشجعتني الحقيقه همم على قبول اني اخرج
في في
برنامج
فانا اتوقع باذن الله ان الليله ااا خاصه
انها كانت مريحه سالت الاخوان همم وانت ان
وجدت حلقات طويله فقال الحلقه طولها وقصه
يعتمد على ما يقدمه هذا شغله مريحه لانه
بعض الاحيان تضع الانسان انه لازم نقدم لك
المعلومات
ربع ساعه معك لكن لما تعطيني الوقت انت
تستفيد
والمشاهد يستهيد وانت في يدك المرونه انك
تبحث عن المعلومات
والوقت الطويل
باي باي
الله يسعدك طيب اقول حاجه
لمحت صوره لانك تقول انت تمثل التاريخ في
صوره للمبنى حقكم اللي في مكه ايه بيت
عمره 100 سنه او اكثر
من 100 سنه
اخوان اللي رايحين واللي رايحين لكنه
واحده من اخواني هناك ملكه
كل الارقام حطموها ما شاء الله بلديه فكه
امانه مكه
ارقام خرافيه الان بيتنا يشوفوا صغير مع
انه زمان وكنا صغار تخاف اصلا
حسب المفردات المعماريه القديمه معايا
رواشين وهذه همم
يمثل الحقبه همم في حقبه جاءت احنا نسميها
في العماره
الفتره الانتقاليه الفتره الانتقاليه هذه
جاءت همم نمط من العماره مستمد من العماره
المكيه القديمه واضيف اليه اللغه
من
العماره الايطاليه في عصر النهضه جاءت عن
طريق تركيا
وانتقلت الى المناطق اللي كانت تحت حكم
الدوله العثمانيه والحجاز من ضمنها همم
فلذلك تجد الان في مكه في فلوس قديمه هي
تمثل الفتره الانتقاليه همم في شيء
اسمه قصر سليمان اوه من الفتره ذيك همم
احنا قصه ظروف علينا مره علينا على
العائله قصه كبيره جدا معي همم
فكان فكانت ارز قديم هي العائله كان مكه
همم هذه مهمه هذه تفيد في المدهش شويه لا
تكلمني عن تخطيط المدن همم اتتفيدك تفيد
المعلومات هذه مكه
همم
في فتره من الفترات ترى همم
الدوله السعوديه الاولى حكمت الحجاز
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه ما حكمتها
في الحجاز او حاجه همم الدوله السعوديه
الثالثه الحمد لله لما الدنيا هذه كله
ابوها والباحث ترى اللي كانت موجوده في
الجزيره همم لكن في فتره من الافاتار
اعتقد انها في الفتره اللي ما كانت ضمن
الحدود الدوله السعوديه
مكه كانت عباره عن اربع مقاطعه مكه نفس
المدينه هذه اللي كانت هي المدينه
اكبر منها
يمكن يمكن في مناطق في اليمن مختلفه ولا
في همم في حضرموت ولا حاجه لكن في ما يسمى
الان الحدود الجغرافيه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
مستدامه خلينا نسميها مستدامه او من قواعد
من قواعد الاستدامه في اداره المدن
فكانت فكان علما صغير يعني ما تتكلم مكه
كان
مازال الصغير ولكنها مدينه حاضره
وكنت مقسمه الى اربع مقاطعات صغرى
ويبدو ان التقسيم اولا التقسيم جغرافي حسب
المناطق منطقه المعابده منطقه اعتقد جرول
منطقه اجياد المنطقه الثانيه
متكامله لكل مقاطعه معايا وكل لا ترجع في
نهايه المطاف للحاكم همم ولكن كان فيها
استقلاليه همم لها اميره لها
ولها سجنها حتى
منطقه المعابده او منطقه
السجن
بيتنا البيت
اه فكانت فكانت في امارات صغيره اداريه
مغامرات حكم امارات اداريه نعم همم
سلسله في في في حكم جدا ليش وصلت جدي هذه
الفتره
اخر من كان حاكم على المعده جدي سعد ابويا
انت ها مع دخول مع دخول مع دخول همم
الملك عبد العزيز والاخوانه وضم الحجاز
الى هذه انت هذه هذه اخر فتره له فكان هذا
بيته والبيت اللي جنبه هذا البيت اللي
ساكنه اهو هو البيت اللي جنبه
الاداره المحليه والحكم ولا سميه اللي كان
يجلس فيه ويحكم بين الناس
ووراها السجن حقه سجن حقه موجود الحين
معايا
الحديده هذه الاصوات
كانت موجوده اخذوها مره مدرسه حق اخوي
خالد
المناطق الاربعه
واستقلالها على شكل المدينه
عمرانيه ولا
اداريا
الاداره وكان وكان سبب التكسير اعتقد له
علاقه ليس جغرافيا وبس اعتقد من خصائص
السكان يعني منطقه المعابده هذه كله بهم
قبائل ومعظمهم قبيله عتيبه فهذا السبب انه
دائما
والمعابده هذه طبعا المعابده مكه لكن زمان
على طرف مكه معك كانها قريه مستقله
ضيعه عند اللبنانيه
لكنها شيء يعني كانت مكه مباشر
هي مكه كلها كانت عاديه حقيقه الامر حتى
المناطق الثانيه ما يسمى حاضره هم كانت
مرجعيهم قبائل يعني يا كريش يا كنانه كلها
قبائل ومعهم بعض بعض
الاخوان اللي اللي جو السلطنه ومكه
استجابه لدعوه سيدنا ابراهيم همم لكن لكن
لكن المعابده وكانت لها خصائص تجاريه انها
كانت مخصصه
ل- اا
لتجاره الماشيه وتجاره الخضروات اي منتجات
زراعيه تيجي من اطراف مكه من هذه وهذاك
السوق حقه فهل فهمت
جغرافيا مختلفه
سكانيا
ومن يدير امورهم من نفسهم فاهم فيها
نوع فيها من الذكاء من او تسهيل عمليه
اداره المدينه معي الان المدن ما في
ارتباط مافي ارتباط بين من يدير المدينه
رئيس البلديه
سكان المدينه
المستدامه الاداره المستدامه للمدن معه
عمليه ارتباط الاداره
بالمدينه او
بالضاحيه زي ما سميتها
اصلا ففي الاداره افضل همم
في جزء من الخطه همم رؤيه
20 30 في احاديث
هي توها في البدايات الامور كلها في
احاديث عن موضوع الاداره المحليه للمدن
اييي لانه ما في غنى عن الاداره المحليه
طبعا الموضوع مختلف الان عندنا يتكلم على
مدن ضخمه جدا
زمام مكه كله متى تتجاوز حاره من حوائر
المدن الان الاوضاع مختلفه لكن المباد يجب
ان لا تختلف معك انه ارتباط الاداره
بالناس
وتوفر للدوره الكثير من المعاناه اللي همم
حفره ولا جبنا لنا شيء تصرخ على من على
مين
الامير ولا رئيس البلديه لانه في بلديه
فرعيه ما هو سامعنا اصلا ما هو سامع
صراخنه فجاه
ما يدري عنه
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوجز باي اس تي سي
[موسيقى]
فهذا الانفصال وبرضو جزء من مشاكل المدن
اللي ممكن نتكلم عنه
جدا
الا من اصحابها
معي
شوف امين مدينه جده معالي يقول لك مو قادر
يسيطر على الاسفلت هذا لانه النظريه
التطبيقات النظريه مي صحيح بالاداره في
اداره مدينه بالطريقه هذه يجب انها تكون
طبعا الحديث لو بقعد اتكلم عن الاداره
المحل المدينه وفوائده وكيف تعمل
ونظرياتها يعني انا لي نظريه انا كاتب
نظريه في موضوع في موضوع كيف اعاده هيكله
المجتمعات الحديثه همم
وفي سوالف فيها سوالف كثيره لليل ااااه
وانا ما ودي ادخل في نفسك اني اني اجلس
اتكلم عن عن عن عن عن عن عن نطاق واحد
لانك لن نغطيه
هاقدر اغطيه باي حاله من الاحوال
ولا على شان ادخل في الكلام هذا حدخل في
همم كلام علمي همم وتفاصيل علميه
ولكن ولكن هذه اذا كانت اقدر اسوي دعايه
لنفسي من خلال برنامج انا كل يوم اثنين
اسويه اثنين مساحه
واسجلها عشان احطها في اليوتيوب
والفايده والفائده همم مختلفه مسوي
ماتريكس في ترابط بين المساحات افقيه وفي
ترابط راسي
عامه للسوالف العامه
والانشاء كل الناس انسان له وجهات نظر
ليست علميه لكنه وجهه نظر قد تقدر هذه
دائما حاطه في اول اثنين من الشهر
الميلادي بنسميها ثنيات بالعامه
لانه الشعب السعودي يعاني سجل اسمعوها
كلكم الشعب السعودي معكم
وهذا اللي يهمني الحقيقه
يعاني يعاني معاناته هامه همم من فهم ما
هي العماره ولا التخصص المعماري
كلكم
كلكم الا شويه عشان ما بقول كلكم الا شويه
فلذلك الشعب السعودي ضاحيه الان
لكل واحد يفتح لمساحه يفتح له سناب ويقعد
يسولف انه يفهم الشعب السعودي كيف تبني
كيف كيف تليس كيف خرابيط وكل العالم
من غير اهله نعم
اه فاصبح الشعب السعودي معرض الى
تشويه في فهم ما هي العمارات
تتفاعل مع واحد غير متخصص
وتتفاعل من اوضه كبيره جدا
من اللي اكثر ووطنيه ضخمه اذا اهدرت حين
اهدنا ثرواتنا
يجب ان لا يهدر
كله لكن حتقدر تحد من الهدر وتخلي الناس
استثماراتها اهم استثمار انت وليست افلام
[تصفيق]
صناعه السياره تويوتا
اهلا واعتقد اني حيه انه
ثقافه الشعب السعودي في نوع في فهم
العماره لن اتكلم عن العماره كما اتكلم
فيها الناس متخصصه عندي الطلاب
او ان كما يحدث يتكلم لفوقيه جدا فوقيه
كبيره جدا وهو يتحدث عن العماره وكانها
طلاسم وكانه يتحدث الى فلاشفه
اعتقد
لكن اجر المحاوله اني احاول اوصل المعلومه
وارفع الثقافه في فهم انه واحد معماريه
باللغه العاديه باللغه البسيطه للناس اللي
تفهمها وهذا المهم اللي جالس انا اكررها
في كل يوم ثاني اثنين شهر
انت تقدر تسوي المبنى تقدر خليني اجيب مثل
خلينا نجيب مثل مضبوط لفهم المدينه
يعني لابد ان الانسان حتى يستمتع بالمدينه
وفهم المدينه
لاني انا اشك ان البعض فاهم ماذا تعني
مدينه
انا متاكد اني اشوف كثير انه في ناس فاهمه
ايش معنى مدينه يتوقع ان المدينه
ليست الا مجموعه مباني مبنيه وبينهم شوارع
اعتقد هذه فهمه وفي خدمات موصله طيب ايش
المدينه
شوف المدينه انا انا بديت انا بديتها
بالناحيه العكسيه قلت له بديت اشرح ما هي
المدينه نزولا
كده الناس
لانك هتبدا من
انا بحاول نتكلم كلمات انجليزيه لانها انا
اعتبرها من اسوء الاشياء ان الانسان
يستخدم كلمه انجليزيه لكن اذا زرقت كل
المال هذه نعتذر للناس كلها اااه لكن من
الافكار المجرده لانه بديت من فوق حتى
ابدى من الافكار المجده وابدا انزل
الافكار المجرده قد ايه يمشي معي فيها
الانسان المتخصص معي همم لكن الناس العامه
الحياه بدونك يا شباب
فقررت في شرح للمدين من تحت الى فوق ان
ابدا بالتفاصيل البسيطه
قال لي اذا تكلمت وغير متخصص يفهمها اول
اول اول اثنين
ترتيب
العمرانيه
بديت اتكلم
مع المدينه
تعرف ترتبط بالمناطق المخصصه شكل لانه
ساكن فيها لكن لو جيت اتكلم عنه اتكلم عن
المناطق الصناعيه
مرتبط بالمنطقه الصناعيه
والمنطقه الصناعيه تشكل اجزاء بسيطه جدا
من المدينه
ايش مشاكلنا اما الناس يقول لك مشاكل لا
والله
ما ادري ما ادري الازعاج ما مرتاح هذه
المشاكل هذه
عارف الصخونه يوم الواحد يجي له سخونه هو
سخونه ما هي مره هذه ما غير انعكاس لمره
الثانيه
فانا بادي اشرح لهم من تحت همم
طبعا الموضوع كبير جدا همم وسويت
النموذج هذا اللي انا معتمد عليه في الشرح
الان صار عبد الرحمن
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد يمكن والله
قبل 20 سنه 15 سنه
جاء امين جديد لجده
وهو في بدايته اني الخصله جده اخليه يقرا
جده بطريقه مختلفه
ما هي المرض الرئيسي لمدينه جده
بدون ما ادخله في متاهات كبرى ولا يدخل
يحوس في الاوراق
والمعاملات ويتحول زي ما يقولون في
الانجليزي
فقلت لا بشبك حسبك قبل ما يغوص في المشاكل
ويجتدلونه في الحفر والمطبات والالغام
اللي ضي علينا جده في نهايه المطاف يروح
يصرف جاء وقته همم
نموذج ثلاثه ثلاثه
كلام محدد جدا في صفحتين بس بس
انا اعتقد للحظه هذه ما قراها ما حد قراها
اصلا وسلم
ونحاس ودخل هو في في الورقيات وفوضى
الورقيات والمشاكل وخلاص وانتهت القصه لكن
الان هو يتقسم من ثلاثه اجزاء انا بعطيك
الخطوط طعام انا داخل في شرح كل حاجه لانه
لو اشرح لك كل حاجه لازم اطلع من الايميل
واقعد اقرا
ولا ودي الحقيقه يعني ههه
اذا وفي كل واحد منهم حوالي 66 مشاكل
رئيسيه اه
من يفهم من يفهم طبعا هي الطابق على معظم
مدن المملكه لكن انا كنت مخصصه على جده
لانه كنت انا في وارد اني اني
ارسلها لامين جدا اللي كان وقتها معين معك
فكان في فهم يعني كان الهدف
انه ترى دور الامين
ليس تنظيف شوارع
ليس والله انا في حوره ولا هناك في
اختناقات
الرئيسي خلق خلق
اقتصاد حي للمدينه دورك الرئيس
انك ازدهار المدينه
همم تطور مدينتك انت لو كل امين حط في
تركيزه
انه مناطبه
اعمال الناس
ما شفت
حقين البلديه هذول اللي منكدين على على
على على
حقين الاعمال كل يوم مغرمين هذا وكل يوم
غرمين هذا كل يوم مقفلين
ما يسوي الحركه بيه لانه الان معتقد انه
دوره
شخصيا ترى الموضوع
انا اتكلم عن وظيفه عامه ما اتكلم عن شخص
باسمه همم
يعتقد انه دوره خمسه المخالفه
يمسك مخالف ما عندنا مشكله
عمله وظائف للناس
الغرام
الى عمله لكن اذا اصبحت انت ما غير ما في
دور الا كل يوم الثاني جايك مراقب بلديه
ولا شركه
الناس قد تؤدي الى مشاكل انا ما بقول له
كثرك المخطي لكن تعامل بحقلانيه
وفي فرق بين الثنتين لانه عملك الرئيس
الرئيس
يعني بعدين اعتقد تروح تشوفها قاعده ولا
الناس كمان ابغى اشوق الناس انا باخدم
مصالحي ابي اخدم مصالح
انا ما عندي مصالح ماليه عندي مصالح
يجتمعوا لي فقط
اجتماعيه للناس
همم ابي اعطيك في موضوع الاقتصادي انا
بمشي عليها بسرعه ولا اشرح لانه شرحت
القونو في الحلقه القادمه عند عبد الله
من النواحي الاقتصاديه في ثلاثه عوامل وفي
هنتكلم عن مدينه انتبه عشان الواحد لا
يروح مختل مدينه
احياء سكنيه عشان لا تروح في لانه في
ادوار اقتصاديه ثانيه للمدينه ما تجيء تحت
موضوع الاحياء السكنيه انا اتكلم عن
الاحياء السكنيه
همم مركز المدينه ولا دورها لا لا ما تكلم
انا اتكلم فقط
معقول في ثلاثه مشاكل في الموحد في
محدوديه وفي تفاوت وفي حرمه
هذا ليه المناطق السكنيه وسكانها فنقول من
المحدوديه الاحياء عندنا في شيء اسمه
محدوديه حيويه القاعده الاقتصاديه للحياه
السكني الحين السكني اقتصاديه
في بعضنا كده احنا ساكتين يجب ان تكون
للحي قاعده اقتصاديه
قاعده اشوف الاحياء الان في في في
الحي ماذا يعني الحي و اقتصاديات الحي منه
فيه
مناطق تسوق وتلقاه شارع فيه للتسوق تلقى
في كوفي شوبس تلقى خدمات ففي قاعده
اقتصاديه
السعوديه
معي ما هي قويه ولكنها موجوده لكن في
اعتقاد حسب
الاحياء شبه معزوله همم حياك كبيره جدا
وما فيها قواعد اقتصاديه ان الناس تعمل في
نفس الحقيقه
النقطه الثانيه
التنوع في القاعده الاقتصاديه الانتاجيه
همم في القاعده الاقتصاديه حتى في الصف
عندنا
وفي قاعده اقتصاديه نوعا عامه ما في تنوع
في القاعده الاقتصاديه معك الهدف ايه انك
تقوي الحي بحيث انه يصبح
ان ان الجزء هذه النظريه ان الجزء متكامل
تتكامل
الكل الكل هنا المدينه فهو انعكاس ورمزيه
اي واحد يقول لك طبعا الحقيقه
يحط لك فيه مطر لا يا اخي لكن حط لي كل
شيء الا الشي اللي ما اقدر احطه
نظريه ان جزء جزء متكامل تتكامل الكل هذه
النظريه هذه النظر يا ابو عبد الله بن
جرير همم تيجي تيجي في موضوع التفاؤل في
نقطتين
يقول لك التفاوت في توزيع الانشطه
الاقتصاديه بين اجزاء المدينه
[موسيقى]
الان يجيك يحط لك النشاط مثلا
السياحي
في المدينه
من الانشطه الاقتصاديه معك وتلقاه
مركزينها في مناطق معينه طيب خلاص
يوم الخميس
معه تقدر تحط واحده في الشركه واحده في
الغرب وواحده في الشمال وواحده في الجنوب
وتقول فيها همم
لا لا لا لا تقدر تقدر انك تقسم مهند لما
الواحد بيتعب بالتفصيل عندك تقدر تقسم
الترفيه الى انواع معينه في ترفيه يحتلوا
خدمات رئيسيه هذه توزعها في مناطق مختلفه
وفي ترفيه ممكن توزعوا على الاحياء مثلا
هدايا وفيها خدماتها في العاب ابطال
الديجيت حطها في كل شيء هذا ما يضرك تقدر
معي لذلك حديقه
ليست حديقه معك قال لي باقول انا انه في
مشكله في التوزيعات معك
ولا هدف الهدف ناريه ونقول ان الحي او
الوحده او الجزء هذا يجب انه يكون متكامل
تيجي تقول اقدر اخليه متكامل 100% يقول لك
لا لكنك تقدر تحاول اكثر شيء انه انك تحقق
في الحياه هذا اكثر اكثر معطيات همم
يحتاجها الانسان الحقيقي موجود في
السعوديه افضل حي في السعوديه
كيف يعني الاحراج هذا كيف سؤالك المحرجه
وهي اكثر المدن واكثر المدن السعوديه
حيويه لا اعتقد
اكثر حيوان اكثر مدينه حيويه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
هذا على نظريه انا ما ابغى ادخل في
العواطف
لا ما ابغى ادخل في العواطف ويجي واحد
يقول لك جده جده
اكثر المدن السعوديه حيويه واكثر المدن
السعوديه قابليه انها تصل الى
تطلب همم
[موسيقى]
الرؤيه ان تكون في ثلاثه مدن ضمن القائمه
الميته جده اقربهم واقل لهم تكلفه للوصول
ليه
في الموضوع الاول
طب خلينا ناخذ لهذه لان هذا الموضوع
الله شاهد
الحين انت انت الان دخلتنا في فحو الامر
اتكلم
بمنطق علمي كامل
بعيدا عن العواطف لان انا اعرف في ناس
الرياض اكثر حيويه ولا وجونك في المنطقه
الشرقيه ترى الرياضه غاليه عليه والمنطقه
الشرقيه غاليه عليك
وجيزان ونجران غالي علينا وفرق بين مدن
المملكه ولا
متر مربع المملكه
في برنامج حق الوجود
بعيدا عن الشمس وبعيدا عن همم
وبعيدا عن الكلام اللي موعد البيت
اشوف المدينه
عشان تقول انها مدينه
خلينا اضبط كلامي بحيث اني اوصل الرساله
بدون ما يصير شوشره لان الموضوع ممكن
الناس تفهمها بطريقه خاطئه
ومثل بعيد مره
مثلا
تقول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
انا اقول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لكن
جدا هابقى ارن بحبك جدا شخصيه
وانا اقرا الاشياء لانه عندي خلفيه علميه
فاقراها بطريقه تختلف عن انسان عادي ماشي
في الرياض
الصغيره توصل الفكره الرئيسيه
غير في مناطق عندنا غريبه طالعه في شمال
جده ما نعرف كيف طلعت لان هذه تحت ظروف
معينه طلعت ونعرف شو الظروف
اللي نعرفها جدا اللي من سنين وليست
كل شهر تمشي في جده
مستحب
وحي
وكله عليه دكاكين وكله اصوات
فوضت جده في شوارع حفظ لم تنظم للطريقه
الصحيحه وحرج اتكلم فيها لكن في لو لو
عامل وجده وشوارعها بطريقه تتحول
شبيهه لشوارع في اوروبا
الان الفوضى قاتله جزء منها
انا بعرف الرياضه من اخذني منه في اوتيل
ماريوت ماريو
دين
في محل جنب الجامعه
غير مبنيه يمين وشمال
بوصل لك الفكره
مبنيه
العمراني في الرياض
من من النسيج العمراني الى الرياض
اول عنصر في نظل المدن الكثافه الصحيحه
الكثافه
السكان في الكيلومتر المربع نعم كم عدد
السكان في الكيلومتر المربع
حنا والحمد لله في يوم من الايام المهندس
علي الشيباني علي الشيباني
قبل 15 سنه
الى الى خمسه ادوار فيله
رفع الكثافه رفعت الكثافه هذه لا يوجد
مدينه بدون كثافه
ضعيفه جدا
تجيد تلقى لك في المنطقه المركزي هذه هذه
ما تحسب في الموضوع
الكورنيش جدا ما يحسب في الموضوع
كثير جدا
انا اقول لكم ما اعرف الرياضات كثيره لكن
راحت المستعجلات للناس
انك تصنع من حضرتك
انا اسمي دايما نكد على السياره
لا تساهل للسياره
وانت معتمد على ايش على السياره لانه كل
شخص فينا معه سيارته معاه نص بنحول
المدينه الى ايش ليست مدينه ناس مدينه
السيارات
فتبدا تعيق السياره
ما تمنعها ما في شيء مدينه اسمها بدون
سياره
كل شيء واحد
دق لفه كامله بدل ما تاخذ المشوار في خمس
دقائق تاخذ ب 10 دقائق السياره
الخير الرياض طالع طلعت امرك في خريطه
الرياض
حواديث
ضخمه واشكال
وروقه واحد جالس يفكر كيف كيف يسوي الرسمه
الحلوه والمنحنيات والكورفات
جدا بسيطه خطوط راسيه وخطوط افقيه
يسمونه الانسان
تصدق الكلام هذا كله لا تصدق الكلام هذا
كله هو لانه كل التشكيلات والاشكال
والخرابيط هذه هذه المدن ليست الا قتل
للمدن الشبكي هو النظام الاسهم وهو الاصح
بعطيك مثل وهذا المتخصصين خرج
تمارس الاحتراف
انا انا انا انا انا انا يهمني اني اوصل
رساله همم ان نص ان ان ان نستطيع ان شاء
الله تحكي لي حجه الرؤيا همم الثلاثه
المدن بطريقه عقلانيه وليس بطريقات
انفعاليه همم وهذه يعني شوف قارن بين
نيويوركتين مختلفتين في تخطيط المدن
نيويورك
الامريكي مخرج من المدينه هذه
انا بسيطه جدا
حتى لما جاءوا يحطوا الكنيسه الرئيسيه
بس كده
اصبحت البلوكات والجرد حق نيويورك
واللي يساعد على ذلك ليش
بساطه النسيج العمراني
واكثر حتى في الناتج في الناتج الاقتصادي
لها ما بداوا يخلقون زوايا
ويانا تعرف الحركات
انت تبدا تخرج ايش تباين بين الاجزاء اذا
اللحظه اللي تخلط تباين بين الاجزاء انت
اضعفت اضعفت اجزاء معي ضخمه نيويورك
اوكي
قريب من البيت الابيض
نفس الكلام انا اقول لك جده جده
تصميم بسيط جدا وعلى منحنى علمي ترى اللي
حطها شركات ما هو بلعب ما واحد جاب ماهو
يحطه سيرجي
ومعهم عباسيين عندهم تجربه
عميقه جدا يا اصلا كل سوالف تخطيط المدن
والعماره والنظريات كلها طالع من عند
الانجليز فهم اعمق من اي دوله ثانيه من اي
شعب من اي شعب ثاني في فهم معنى تخطيط
المدن معك فهم اللي اسسوا جده
وجده مؤسسه صح في خلال مرحله معينه نظر
شيله اللي حدث في مرحله من المراحب معايا
المدينه الى اصلها وكم من شغله الانجليزي
وقف معي واكمل على خطتهم
سهله الوصول اليه
مستمر
واعتقد الان تغلبت الدوله على الاشكاليه
هذه كانت عندنا مشكله نزل مناقصه
خلاص نزل مناقصه واقل المناقصه خذه خلاص
الدوله
همم 100 جيب لكزس
هادخل انا واياك في منافسه خلاص انت هتجيب
جبل اللكزس هون حجيب جيب اللكزس ما هيكون
فيه الموضوع
فذلك المناقشه تنزل على على على اقل اقل
واحد فاهمها لكن لما تجيني في تخطيط مدن
وفكر
وتخصصات وعالم وعمر تقول لي مناقصه ويدخل
معي مكتب هندسي 10 انفار في جده جالسين
متاكيد ها يتنافس مع شركه همم
بريطانيه ولا مكتب بريطاني همم عنده من
الخبره 100 سنه ولدي
طيب ماشي يا بابا تقريبا
هابقى اقول لك امري الى الله امري الى
الله بقوله مره من المرات جالسين فيها في
الاستديو عند الطلاب وكان
فيه زميلنا
مجروح كان حي الله الله يرحمه حي وميت
اسمه معتز سلامه اخو الدكتور الدكتور
فوزيه سلامه
اهو فريق وهو يرتاح لي انا لانه حاله حافه
الجنوب اييي وصل مرحله انا حافه بين ههه
على حافه الجنون يعني
يقول انا جيت رحت درست ومتعلم يقولوا يوم
رجعت مصري يقول قلت انا
راح انقد مصر
هانقذ مصر مره بالعلم حقه عندي همم
رجاء عندنا يدرس عشان بس بيخرج من الجو
اللي كان فيه وجه عندنا يدرس وهو ممتاز هل
مره من المرات انا جالسه في الاستديو وهو
يروح هو في التخطيط المدن انا قسم العماره
وعنده الاستديو حقي زي ستار بوكس كنت
محوله
استديو صارف عليه من جيبي
وجاني قال لي عبد الله قلت له
اجتماع
بيسووا مخطط لجده
انا واياه انا بسيارتي انا اسوق وماخذه
معي يعني
فاهم
يمكن في 60 نفر
وفي واحد ما ابغى اقول جنسيته ولكن جاي من
بريطانيا من شركه مدري من فين جايبينها
ولكنه عربي هو من اللي يعرف اللي يبيع لك
ايه
انا عارف الحركات ديك ولا كده يعني
وفيه يعني ايه ما ابغى نفسي شباب
تبكين الحين انا باوصل لك حاجه ان شاء
الله ما اضيع الهرجه حقي انا اخاف اني حقي
يفكرني انت بتعرف تضيع الامور كلها
صحيح انطلق بالرؤى معينه لكنها تبنى على
تعضدها الارقام
والعقلانيه والقرار العقلانيه
حنا بعيد واخر الصاله
والناس جالسه تتكلم انه لا نسوي من هنا
اقواس وهنا يتكلموا كده ويطرح بالتسويق
طبعا كده
المهم
بتكلم امري
من القصص اللي لازم يستشهدوا بها الناس
اتكلموني
وانت شايف البهله العاديه يعني
وانت شايف الاخ هذا اللي جاي من الشركه
اللي في لندن هذا اللي عربي شايف الحركات
حقه ثانيه
الحين
بس انا حاضر فلازم انا اقول كلمه اللي صح
غلطانه
اقول الاخ هذا اللي يبيع بياع الورد هذا
يصوتوا خليهم يصوتوا ويرفعوا يدينهم ارجع
كبيره ومثل
وانا تراني اصلا ما هو المفترض اكون هنا
لانه الاحد عزمني ولا شيء لكن ما دام انه
الباب مفتوح سامحتونا بالدخول وجودي هنا
يتطلب
يتطلب اني اتكلم مع ان الكلام اللي جالسه
هذا انا ماني فاهمه وانا من باب جهلي
بالامور ودي استفسر
الله يستر عليه
دكتور جميل الليله يضحك
اول نقطه
انت الحين جامع الاخوان دوله
وهذول ياسين يصوتوا
عشان يصوتوا انا افهم عشان يصوتوا هذول
المهني
فلازم يكون لها ناحيه قانونيه لانك انت
يفترض انك جالس تسوي مخطط عام يشك المدينه
باي صرفه باي منطقه علمني اياه عشان افهم
انا بس فقط لا غير انا ما اعترض انا اللي
اعرفه ان اللي يصوت اما انسان منتخب او
انه يصور لانه في امر
نظامي من سلطه عليا عندنا اعطتهم الحق في
التصوير
فهل هذول
اهل جده عندما افترض
او انه المنتخب
ما ادري يمكن في طريقه ثالثا انتم متابعين
بس ما يهمنا ما يهمنا فيها خلاص انت يا
وزهريه
النقطه الثانيه
انت جاي تسوي مخطط وشركه حقهم والمكتب
حقكم يسوي مخطط المدينه جدا
بالله مهمتكم
تحطون خطه لتفعيل جده وتنميه اقتصادها
وتنميه
الوظائف وتنميه هذه بحيث انها تسير بيئه
للانتاج والناس تعيش
وترتكبها واقتصاديا
ولا تركت الامر المهمه الصعب
فرحته تنطوني تحطون شجره فوق العماير ولا
ما تحطوا شجره فوق الهملايا
تحياتي الموضوع
يزعلون علي زملايا كلهم لكن دخلت في
تفاصيل قلت مهمتك
ومهمه
ليس شيئا الان الشجر
وتنميتها
وامورها الاجتماعيه
صرامه الانجليزي
لتطوير المدن الى الناحيه الاخرى الناحيه
العباسيه ان المدينه تروحي اشكال ومدري
ايش ونضحه السحابه والسوالف هذه الامان
لكن
هذا يجاوب لك على موضوع ان يتحول تخطيط
المدن
من عمليه مهمه لتحفيز الاعمال لانه انا
شاب من مدينه
جميله لكن ما تقلق لي الاعمال
حطها في جميع المجلات العالميه اذا ما
توفر اذا ما تخفض البطاله
بين سكانها اذا ما حققت رفعت الناتج
الناتج الوطني للمدينه لانه رفع انها
النتيجه الوطني للدوله عباره عن ايه هو
الناتج الوطني لكل مدينه مجمعه بعض الخدم
ومناطق اخرى وهو في نهايه المطافئ واحنا
نتكلم
السعوديه
وما في شيء اسمه لا تجي القوم الاسود
لكن اول شيء لا حلو لا حلو يمكن تحقيقه
اذا لم يستند الى قاعده اقتصاديه
اي حلو
مهما يكون جميل وهذا
بس ما تقدر
يصير اتصرف فيها عبدي بدون عوائد
لازم تخطيط المدن يستند في الاول
يستند الاول على خلق القاعده الاقتصاديه
القويه للمدينه وسكانها ولما فعل سكانها
الامانه عند صلاحيات اصلا
صلاحيات الوزاره
الحقيقي ولا ادخل في هذه لكن لكن يوم كانت
المدن جده كانت جزء من التغطيه حق المدينه
كانت القاعده الاقتصاديه والاعمال والدنيا
تغيرت من سرج اكشن للالعاب ما اعرف لكن
اعتقد لم تتغير انا لا اعتقد ان اتغيرت
على الطرق اللي انتم تقولوه لو سيارات ولو
تغيرت في فتره ما اه واتسحبت الصلاحيات
اعتقد الان الان في ضمن رؤيه 2030 وضمن
توجهات سمو ولي العهد اللي جلسه الان
لجلسه نسويها جالس اشتغل على هذا الاساس
انا اعتقد انه انها معادله
لن يتم تحقيق رؤيه سموليه العهد في كل
الاجزاء الا انه كمان بعد المدن تشتغل على
الضوء هذا انها تخدم القاعده الاقتصاديه
للدوله موت تحول بلديه وامانه والامم هذا
كله عشان ننظف شوارع
ولا عشان ما ادري ايش فلت ولا صيانه مدينه
هذا هو يقول لك مهمه
الان شوفي اذا اذا القاعده الاقتصاديه تم
الاهتمام بها في المدينه انت تعرف ان جده
كانت هذه
مو كانت الدوله الصوبه الفروسيه كانت تنتج
فلوس للخزينه
المدن هذه
الميزانيه العامه تستفيد منها الان حنا
حولنا الى خرم بس يصبوا فيها فلوس بدون
عوائد بدون حوائج الان تكلفت الدوله
الماليه
انه على الاقل يا اخي شيلي نفسك بنفسك
معايا
لكن على الاقل تخفض الضغوطات الميزانيه
الدوله
والدوله السيره الاموال المهيا للدوله
للاستثمارات اكثر فائده لنا كدوله
العامه
سعر الظروف خربناها شويه نقدر نردها مره
ثانيه
السمو ولي العهد انك تحولها مركز اقليمي
على الاقل بوابه لافريكا والمناطق هذه
انت عندك مشكله
الى انه اصبح الطريق
نفسي الا دخلت طريقه التحليه ماني قادر
الف وارجع ليال رحت على خير ولفيت كل يوم
والثاني نكد عليك طيب لا لا لا
ينكد علي بنظام لان لو عرفت من الاساس كان
طلعت قبلك قبل ما اجيك بربع ساعه شاهد
القضيه بس يعني لما انا ابني طريق واحط
طريق سريع
واخذ مباني واسع الطريق هل اقدر ارجع
قده
الفارسي
ليش بس هو الحمد لله انه كبر الشوارع الان
جده ما تحتاج ريال واحد لنزع الملكيه لانه
شوارعنا ضخمه 100 متر 80 متر 70 متر
وكلها مبنيه وكلها اماكن تجاريه انت بتخيل
القطاع هذا تخيل انك تخليه تجاه واحد وجده
بكل سهوله ها ها تقدر تخليها في اتجاه
واحد كل شوارع جده داخليه وخارجيه سواء
اتجاه واحد نعم نعم
بدون اشارات
قوي قوي عادي يعني
الطلاب حقيقي مره سواء تجربه هذه
عند دكتور كان طالب اسمه جمال الغامدي
اعتقد القى المخطط عنده اللي سوينا بها
لكن في امكانيه انك تحول اوك يمكن 100%
تحولها لكن تقدر شي 90% من همم من اشارات
المرور
لا تجاه واحد اتجاه واحد
ثلاثه خطوط ثلاثه خطوط عليكم في اتجاه
الصوت هذه قول
معنا خلاص
vip
اكثر شيء 20 متر انت تبغى السيارات كلها
واحد
ثلاثه
وتقدر تحط مواقف يمين وموقف جماعي انت
تقدر تحط كل الفوضى اللي تبغاها في 30 متر
اصغر شارع في جده الان من الكبار هذا 66
متر باقي لك كم 40
في شوارع امريكا
طيب
اي واحد يقول عبد الله بني ينادي بنت
سواها ثلاثه حطها اربعه
حطها خمسه مع اني ما احب انك تكثر معايا
انا دائما مع العقلانيه معي في التعاطي
معك
تحط تعرف الشوارع حقنا هذا ما احط لك
باركنج فوكو
في فرنسا
وانسنا
تحول الى بيئه خضراء و لازم لازم
حدايقنا تكون مكعبره كذا السنترال مو لازم
تقدر حدايقك تصير طوليه
متكامله تقدر تمشي في جده من اولها الى
اخرها كبيره جدا لكن تقطع المسافه وتقدر
تجيبي
الدكاكين هذه انت لحيت الدكاكين لحيتني
لحيه الوظائف
حياه الترفيه بدل ما تقول لي الترفيه عشان
اشرب لي قهوه اجي في شمال جده يمين
والشوارع كله ترفيه صارت بالنسبه لي سعر
جنوب جده شرق جده كله عنده شارع العريضه
هذا نعم اللي فيه احمله كل شيء اللي هو
متصل
اولادك
واولادي يقدرون ينتقلون للمدارس حقتهم من
خلال تقدر النظيف
تعمل كل شيء في بالك وتنقل نقله فظيعه
بدون ما تنزع ملكيات
وباقل الاثمان ما في شيء تقول لك بلاش
بلاش ما في شيء
طبعا هذا كلامي انا عشان ما حد يدخلني
متاهات ذحين يقول كاني اتحدث باسم الدوله
انا ما اتحدث باسم الدوله تحدث بافكار
عبدالله بالانجليزي تقدر انا لا يجوز لا
يجوز اني احسلك الشارع وارفع لك من قيمه
الشارع ويرتفع عقارك وان جالس كده مغير
متلقي من المال العام اطور شيء عشان
تستفيد انت لا انا اقدر احمل لك جزء من
تكلفه هذه لانك انت مستفيد من رفعه
والمستثمر العاقل صاحب الملك العاقل يجب
انه ايش يدعم خاصه اللي ما عنده مواقف ايش
استفاد منها
لكن لما احول لك الجزء اللي امامك
فخم
معبر عمراني جيد
حجاره
والمويه والشلالات والخرابيط هذه نبعد
عنها بالهدوء بالهدوء
تحويل جدا الى مدينه حيويه باقل تكلفه
ممكنه
ونساعدك
كيف شفت تجربتهم في الواجهه البحريه
تحويل الشارع الى مشاهد
والبسكليتات
المدينه
بس لكن لا تؤثر في مستوى المدينه
فوضى يا شيخ فا والله انا ماني عارف مين
اللي جاب فكره
السلم يقول لك
في الرياض
من المبنى الى المبنى ما بين رصيف ابو متر
حتى ما تمشي عليه ترى ما يحط لك عريضه
ومواقب سيارات مدري تخش منها لانه مخبطين
في بعض واحد موقف كذا والثاني وراء
لبنانيه
فيها مشكله ما تقدر تحولها نعم او انها
صغار ليهن
اصلا حيعرفون انه ما هو اعمامهمش يحتاج
للتحويل
لكن انا متاكد جدا
40 سنه هتكون الشوارع هذا الشوارع عظيمه
جدا والله نظيف
فؤاد عسيري يقول ان الخبر هي المدينه
الاكثر حيويه في السعوديه واللي قابل انها
تقدر تكون تتحول الى نموذج حيوي انا ما
اعرف انه همم
دائما همم الطريق
يمكن قبل 40 سنه ولا 35 سنه فما اعرفها
الحقيقه
ولكن هو خبير هو اذا قال شيء انا متاكد
انه فاهم من اللي يقوله فؤاد همم
لكني ما اعرف احكم عليها لكني انا عارف
شيء واحد عارف جدا
واعرف انه جده اااه
عارف الجوهره
اللي اللي في الارض اللي غير لامعه ما هي
ملمعه همم قيمتها فيها
عدم تلميعها عدم نحته وعدم هذا لا يلغي
قيمتها معي لكن تلميعها ومدري ايش يسمونه
هي اللي ترفعها قيمه ولكن مثلا
اللي قبل شهر شهرين همم
الهيئه الملكيه همم
لتطوير جده وحاجه كذا لاسمه
ورئاسه سمو ولي العهد اه
اه
متاكد انه الامور هتختلف طبعا شمول اعاده
امام ملفات كثيره جدا
وهو يتعامل مع جميع الملفات همم
طبعا احنا عشان سكان جده
يقربنا بسرعه في موضوع تطوير جدا ان شاء
الله كلها دولتنا في نهايتها لكن تعرف
بصفت اني جالس اني اروح المحل ثاني الا في
جده يعني ماني من اللي جالسين يقول لك
اليوم عايش في جده بكره بنقول لها خلاص
ومتقاعد في جده انا ودي قبل الواحد ما
يموت بدايه
بدايه
بدايه نحت وسقل الجوهره
في جزء عاطفيه انا اعشق جده لكن ما تعاطف
الكلام حقي اتعاطى من ناحيه علميه وما
تعاطي من ناحيه يا حلوه هذه هو عندي خلفيه
كامله وعندي خلفيه ترى الملكه انت تعرف
الدكتور
الحضاري فانا افهم في اموره
كل صح 100% لكن اعتقد اني اقرب للصحه من
من الخطا طيب كيف تقرا مشروع جده
اي مشروع يضاف لجده
مضافه
للقيمه الكليه
الحقيقه كانت محطه تحليه قديمه جدا وكانت
مدري تحويل الى شيء مفيد
محرك حضري اوقات
للتنميه
جيد ان يكون في مشروع هنا ويكون طبعا انا
اتمنى مع وسط جده
او اخرى احنا ما نبغى ما نبغى نركز
التنميه في اتجاه واحد في جده لانه صنعاني
نفس المشكله اللي ادى الى
اجزاء شعبيه انه اذا ما المدينه زيها
الجسم انسان
الاجزاء الجنوبيه ليسا ليس تدهورت وليس
يقال انه صارت فيها مشاكل
التنميه اللي تحرك التنميه وتوفر مع اسميه
اكسجين الحياه للاحياء والمناطق هذه
المستوى جده كلها معك
ولكن ولكن التشبيه حق حق موضوع الاكسجين
وموضوع الجسم وموضوع الغرغنينا ينطبق على
المدينه 100% طيب اذا انت تقول اليوم فيه
العشوائيه والتخبط في البناء في جده في
السنوات ال 20 من 30 الماضي كيف تقراه في
مكه
في مكه
مكه مختلف
وتفاصيل مختلفه
وانا
حدث انه في مره في لابحاث يمكن دكتور يمكن
والطيران حول الارض والانشغال بالعمل
اليومي كان عندي متسع من الوقت العمل
الفكري معايا
تحول من عمل فكري مجرد
وتخش فيها ابحاث من هذا النوع وبعض
الاحيان تتحول الى انك تجري جري ما تقدر
تفكر انه في عمل لازم تنجزه الحرم
المشاريع الحراميه المرحله زمان
سويت نموذج في دراسات
اسمه النموذج
هذا اختصار لكلمه اركتكشر بمعنى
النموذج النموذج عمراني معماري نموذج
معماري عمراني لتنميه مكه الامتحان
كمون هذا سؤالك تذكر انك فتحت مكه موضوع
مكه فانا بس ارسل لك في ما لدي من معلومات
تجارب شخصيه
في مكه
جزء من الاجابه على سؤالك
مسابقه
الجامعه
السعودي الملك عبد العزيز عندنا جامعه
المؤسسه
عرض الجامعه نحن دائما الاوله
هذا موضوع التعليم موضوع ثاني ممكن نناقش
فيه
هذا في منافسه كلها السعوديه لكن
الولاء للجامعه الملك عبد العزيز
دخلنا بمشروع
ما ادري كم نحن سوينا لنا فريق مسابقه
التصميم جبل عمر
فاضيه جبل تطبيق
الحين الريجيين
وهذا الغلطه اللي غلطناها احنا
الناس
يفترض عندهم خبراء للتكييف
هم التقيمهم مشي حالك
نظراتهم يتفرجون في المجسمات طيب روح اللي
يعجبهم يقول والله هذا حلو
تطبيق
لناظريه عندنا نظريه ام موديل مواد هذا
نموذج
تنميه المدن
موضوع بالنسبه لنا اكبر من جبل عمان جبل
عمر ليس الا تطبيق نحو تنميه مكه
المناظير المناظير
والمجسم حلو شكل المبنى حلو مهما المشكله
في الموضوع
لمكه
بطريقه احترافيه
وسلمنا المشروع على اساس ايه نظام
تنموي لمنطقه لمكه المكرمه
والتطبيق على جبل عمر خلاص خلاص
الثانيين المكاتب الثانيه
حلم المحطه المسابقه حتى النوادي والدنيا
كده
وشوق وافتتاح
الله يرحم الملك عبد الله كان ولي العهد
ويتفرج
اذكر التلفزيون طلعت يعني
زعلت انا
مره وكده مدري ايش في يوم جو جنب حقنا
عبد الرحمن
بسبب ما احتكروا المشروع
من اللي جايه ما ادري انا مو شغلي معي لكن
هذا اللي سمعته في التلفزيون انا زعلت بقى
مزعجه بطريقه مخيفه
عباسيه
ههه
[ضحك]
كنت انس محاضره هو كان وقته حق
اللجنه العقل ما هو اللجنه العيش هذه
العمره مدري حاجه
المعماريه لجعل من جمعيه معماريين مدريد
وانا جيت الحلم عندي كله هو مسوي ذيك
المحاضره تجد وقتها اذا ما خانتني الذاكره
اكثر من 90 سلايم
كل التقرير هذا حولته الى سلايدات انميشن
حفره
وصاحب صديق جدا
يمكن والله 501
المهندسات والدنيا وفي بعض
ايام
بعض
في كل مجموعه لازم يطلع لك سفيهين
ثلاثه اما من باب غيره اما من باب عيونك
المهم وانا اطلع ههه
الساعه 8:00 مدري ايش قلت
انا عارف كميه العلم اللي عندي مصممها
بحيل اذا قالوا لي ساعه اعرب متى توقف
بدون ما اخل وكل ما كل ما كنت شفت الجو
الطيب ابغى امدد في الشرح لانه كل ما توغل
في الشرح كل ما اعتقد انه كرامتي رجعت نعم
انا ما اهمني
احد يهمني
في خيارين
انا بتكلم مع اني متوقف
والله ما اعرف انتهي في نصف ساعه في ساعه
20 ساعه انا مو شغلي
اللي عندكم خيارات اما كلكم تقولوا لي وقف
اتوقف واحد اثنين طفش يضرب الباب يسحب
نفسه ويمشي
اربع ساعات
الاسد والجريح
الناس هدوء
وتقدري بعدين
[موسيقى]
الشريط انا ما عندي نسخه من صحيح الشاهد
اربع ساعات ونص
خلاص الخارجي
[موسيقى]
ان ترجع تسالني عنك
وانا خلصت كده
والناس هاديه ما فقدتها عرفت اني نجحت لان
لو فقدت الناس
والله العظيم والله العظيم
عرفت وقتها اني
سيطرت
يفقد الجمهور انا بعد اربع ساعات
من جنب المشروع يقولون عبد الله
بالانجليزي
منهم مهندس واقف
مع اللقطه واللي تعرف قال والله العظيم ما
حد درى ان الموضوع كذا
الناس كلها قالوا معقول عبد الله بن جريدي
مسوي زي كده
مكه مكه والمدينه
مكه والمدينه
كل دول العالم
تعتمد قاعده في تنميه المدن اذا كانت
المدينه ذات ذات مركز واحد يحاولون يخلقون
مراكز متعدده واستراتيجيه
دول اوروبا
تقدر تطبق تعدد المراكز في جميع المدن
السعوديه الا مكه والمدينه
اي واحد اي انسان ما عنده العمق الكافي
يعتقد
او يجيك شركه
اجنبيه
مكتب هندسي اجنبي اول ما يتبادر في ذهنه
هذه الاستراتيجيه المطبقه في كل محل في
البيت في ستين مركز لها
لا تستطيع ان تطبقها في مكه والمدينه ليش
انت لما تطبق مركز اخر انت تخلق منافسه
لمركز الرئيس السيسي المشكله
فلذلك يجب وهذه ان شاء الله اللي يستمعه
يتعامله مع مكه والمدينه يعني يسمعون هذه
من عبد الله بن جنيدب وانا اعتقد انه صح
واقرب للصح
اذا جاءكم احد يتكلم عن تعدد المراكز في
مكه والمدينه دوروا غيره
دوره غيره
ويجب التركيز على اهميه المركز وفرد
التنميه
عضه المركز وحول المركز الى عاداه
الى اداه
لتقويه الشرايين النابغه من
لفرد التنميه
لكن ما يحدث الان انه
بيحاولون في استراتيجتها
الحقيقيه
ثلاث سنوات
مع حنا اللي جبنا فريق ام ام لتطوير مكه
والمدينه والمشاعر
[موسيقى]
مكه والمدينه شركه ام ام
بعدين يعني الاسباب معينه سجلته
خارج خارج الموضوع النقاش فيها معي همم
الذاكره ميل الدرجه هذه طيبه
2005 2005 2006
المنطقه المركزيه بمكه والمدينه خطا
المباني
الاقتصاديه هي كل ما تيجي تتناقش واحد
يقول ياخذ الارض مرتفع يا اخي الارض مين
مرتفع الارض لا قيمه لها خلينا نفصل
بالكلام عشان الناس لا احد يقول الارض ولا
قيمه لها والدليل والدليل كالعاده انا
ابغى ابيعك مليون متر في الربع الخالي
تشتريها تشتريها مني ب 2000 ريال
مليون متر تقريبا
ايش اللي يخلي قيمه الارض غاليه سؤال قيمه
الارض
قيمه الارض
ليس لها انما للمنفعه الحاصله منها
هذه انت تدفع قيمه للمنفعه وليس للارض ما
القيمه
المتر المربع غالي في المنطقه
في مكه في في
ما اعرف فين في النوريه ليش ليش هناك
المتر ب 500 ريال وعنده وعنده الحرم
بمليون هنا السؤال يبغى يجب
علشان لما تيجي الواحد وتقول خفض التنميه
وجاء لك بالكلام المعاكس قال لك مثل الارض
غالي لا يا حبيبي هو غالي لانك سمحت انت
بتعدد الادوار فيه فبصدر التشوه لسعر
الارض مصدر التشريعات اللي سمحت بذلك لكن
لو قلت الارض
في المنطقه الملكيه 10 ادوار
يصبح مصدر
ايش ليس التشوه في الانظمه انما حساب
القرب الى الحرم
فيصير الارض القريبه من الحرم اعلى من
الارض بعيده عن الحرم لكن انت اذا شوته
50 60 70 دور انت جالس تعضد مين الفائده
لمين للمتر المربع اللي قريب من الحرم
وتمنع عن المتر المربع البعيد عنك
العكس يجب ان يكون
بمعنى تخفض اذا تبغى توصل الى توازن
سعري للارض
بسعر الارض او القيمه للقيمه الارض يجب
انك توازن بين
المنفعه اللي حاصله منهم بمعنى مادام
الارض القريبه من الحرم من فعلتها من
القرب
ما اعطي لها حسنه الارتفاع الزياده علشان
اخفضي اخفض قيمه الارض على طول
الارض البعيده على الحرم
فيها مضره البعد فاعطي له منافع اكثر لكن
كل ده حتى الارض البعيده والافضل كلها
تعتمد
تعتمد في الاساس على الاستمتاع من الحرم
اما اي تشوهات اخرى يجي واحد يقول لك مركز
ثاني لمكه لن تستطيع تنافس المركز فلذلك
اقر اقر قبل ما تسوي اي حاجه انه مكه
والمدينه
منفعتهم الرئيسيه يجب انها تستجلب من وجود
الحرم وانه الحرم لا استطيع فانا مدينه
مكه المدينه
تبدا التنظيمات حقتك نعم تكون اكثر
حقلانيه في التعاطي لكن بجيك واحد دحين
تكلمت تقول يا ابن الحلال هل يجوز تعطي
الارتفاعات هذه يقول انا كيف
اجيب المستثمر الخاص الله
الله
خفض الارتفاع وحط تشريعه كانها 10 ادوار
قيمه الارض اصلا انخفاضات انت ساعدت
المستثمر الخاص بانك خبطت القيمه لكن لا
تيجي على ارض انت معطيها سامح لها ب 100
دولار او مفتوحه
وتنتج سعر عالي وتقول له المستثمر تعال
طبعا
انت تعرف بالطريقه هذه اللي اقولها هيك
المناطق البعيده في مكه مكه
مركز وشرايين اذا اذا قريت بالمركز
والشرايين في جده في مكه
وبنات عليها النموذج التطويري النموذج
اللي حطيناه هناك مكه انتهت مكه
الناس العاديين لديهم من المقدره في
التفكير
وفهم المعطيات اكثر بعض الاحيان من
المخططين ومن المعماريين ومن المهندسين
طالع طالع بحب اشبك خريطه
خريطه واحده
كيف كانت مكه وكيف كانت تشتغل مكه
وبسط النموذج اللي كانت تشتغل عليه مثلا
هو شغال لانه كانت مكه عايشه
واعتقد انه في مكه كله مكه في مكه قبل ما
قبل 20 سنه 30 سنه
في ثناياها جميع ادوات تنميتها وهي اللي
استمدت منها النموذج التنمويه
ويجب كل مخطط يوضع لمكه انه كل قطعه في
مكه فوق جبل تحت جبل في اي مكان ان انه
يصلها اوكسجين الحياه
اي منطقه فيها تشوهات لا يصلها اوكسجين
الحياه
ما تعانيه مكه الان
في التخطيط يبدولي
ليس فهم عميق
للمشكله ليس فهم حقيقي
ليس فهم حقيقي لكيفيه
صناعه مدينه مكه
مكه
قومي يا بنتي كمان اعرف انا كيف ايش هذا
ايش جابت 30 دولار
في 30 دور
كيف وصلت قال والله
معدل البناء
كسر
الحرم يعني
طلعت 30 داره طيب
وبعدين
الطويله والارض اللي وراها مخيفه
او تموت او ارض ضخم يعني مساحات ضخمه من
الارض
على المهندسين
اجيب لهم مثل زمان قديمه
حبيبي من الكره البعيده ديه
حلوه المشكله
اليوم عشان اجيب القصه كامله
تلفزيون مع واحد شايف
شايف
يعني كيف انتم كيفكم
اعدموه في بعض الاحيان المهندسين
بطريقه طيبه ان شاء الله بدات تلقاها انتم
تحطها بعدين لكن التغريده تكون ما فادوا
انا
التعمق في فهم
تهمك في فهم المشكله مهم جدا
وتبسيط الحل مهم جدا الحل يجب تبسيطه لكن
الفهم يجب ان يكون محققه يعني تدخل في كل
شيء لن تفهم
مشكلتنا
وهذه تراها
حتى انا بعض الاحيان تيجيني انا نبسط
الفهم
معظم مشاكل
المدن اعقد شيء صنعه صنعه الانسان واعطي
شيء في الفهم
فلذلك عندنا تبسيط مخل في فهم
التصوير هذا
كله مناظر يسوونه
يا اخي يا اخي المدينه معقده جدا اذا لم
تفهمها لن تعرف تحلها لكن اذا جيت تحلها
اذا عقدت طريقه الحل فانت مخطي يجب ان
الحل يكون بسيط مكه كالاتي
يعترف من يتعاطى معها انها مدينه ذات مركز
واحد لا يوجد موضوع
تعدد المراكش شيله
ناس كثير بيحاولون
هذا اول شيء ثانيا اعتمد على الشرعيه
الشرايين مكه القديمه وادي ابراهيم خالي
اه اعتمد انه تشريعاتك تؤدي الى التوازن
في سعر العرض بين الارض البعيده والارض
اللي جنب الحرم همم اعتمد شيء ثالث على
مواضيع الوحده الوحده العمرانيه لمكه
الوحده العمرانيه تعتمد على
التغذيه التغذيه من الشرايين هذه
وتوفير الاكسجين لاعمق نقطه في البلوكات
هذه
التفاصيل كثيره ما بداخلك فيها لكن
التعاطي مع مكه
لن يكون
بالتعاطي مع اي مدينه اخرى مع جده مختلفه
نهائيا سيناري والتفكير مكه حاله خاصه
يجب ان تكون خاصه والتفكير خاص والتعاطي
معها خالص انا دخلتها وعرفت تفاصيل كثيره
عن مكه
وفي ناس همك
وبسط الحل و اعتقد تسيطر عليها المدينه
ذات مركز واحد لكنها تختلف عن مكه
مكه طبوغرافيه واوديتها وتشكيلها واوضاعها
تختلف وتتطلب حلول عمرانيه اكثر وابتعدوا
عن السيارات والحلول المقاولبه وابتعدوا
وابتعدوا في مكه عن
الانميشن والحلو والحجه الاشكال العباسيه
والمباني العباسيه وهذه شكلها حلو وهذي
شكلها وهذا السؤال هذه بعدين في الطبق
الاخيره لانه الحلول دائما طبقات حلو
الطبقه الاولى والثانيه والثالثه والرابعه
بعدين في الخامسه والسادسه طبقت هالشكل
المعماري ما ادري طبق اخيره جدا ما هي مكه
هتشتغل بدونها لكنها اضافه
كان حلو اولا المدن
تصاب اي مدينه لحالها في الدنيا زي ارجع
الجسم تصاب بالسرطانات تصاب بضعف القلب
تصاب بك نفس امراض الانسان تقدر تحطها
تشبهها في المدينه طولت انا صح
لا تقول كده
في نفس الوقت اليوم
الفرق بين تستقبل المنطقه المركزيه
وتستقبل مكه فرق بين كلمتين
انا ساكن مكه
لاني اشتغلت المخطط العام حق كل الناس انا
كنت صاحب قرار في المخطط العام حقها
فعارف على مستوى التفاصيل والدايت وهذه
واشتغلت الحرم انا عارف الحرام تفاصيله
المنطقه المركزيه واعرف ايش يحتاج واحد
عارف كل الكلام هذا همم واعرف
وعدتك ان احد احد
يعني ايش اللي الولد اللي ما ما لكنه
اعتقد اني اذا تحدثت عن مكه اتعتقد ان
اتحدث بفهم
وعندي الجرعه
وعندي الجرعه اني اقول ما اعتقد انه هو
الصواب
واعتقد اني اقول الصواب حتى لو اجمعت
الناس على خطا عند الجرعه اني اقول
ولا اشتهي فيها ولا اجامل في في هذا اه
لكن اعتقد اني انا عارف ايش تحتاج مكه وفي
ناس غيري في ناس صغيره ان شاء الله يكونوا
عارفين همم لكن اعرف شيء واحد
انه يجب التعمق في الفهم
يجب التعامل في الفهد
يجب التعلم في الفهم
والامتناع عن
منهج التفكير المعتاد
والابتعاد عن
الحلولبه الجاهزه
ويجب الابتعاد عن التفكير اني سويت كذا في
جده اذا انا اسوي في الرئه في جدك مكه كذا
يجب
عدم نقل التجارب مباشره خاصه ارجع واقول
انا دائما اقول لكل مدينه لكن مكه بشكل
خاص
يجب عدم الرحم يجب عدم
الاستسلام
للحلول السهله
الذهبي
كلامك هذا يقلب راسي
ها ها اذا تبغى شغله ما تبغى تضبط مكه
ويجب الفهم العميق يفهم المشكله في بعض
الاحيان الانسان
بانه فاهم المشكله
واصرف معظم مجهودك وانت في اي مؤسستك لفهم
المشكله
في في مكه
المشاكل اللي كانت بتعاني منها مكه في هذا
المشروع بس لما تعمق المشكله واحده من
الاشياء هذه الشهر
وكنت خايف انه يورطني في شيء ما وانا فكنت
همم يعني كنت شويه ما ودي انا انا مرتاح
اريد اسولف ولا عندي مشكله معي همم فكان
في ظروف ما تخليني عشره لكن
اذا تبغاني اقول لك السالفه بتفاصيل عندك
وقت طويل
الساعه
9:30 كبيره
[ضحك]
يعني ما دام انهم مسجله للتاريخ في بعض
الناس
استغلوا اوضاع
وتلاعبوا بمعلومه
في ظهرها صح ولكن قبل الناس تفهم شيء اخرى
انا ارجو بنفسي اني استاذ رايله
مشروع راقي
انه يدخلونا في اللغوصه همم
الانساني اللي ما تقدم ولا توخر في شيء
لكن
الامر هذا كله من يقول ان التصميم هذا
سواها
دخلونا واحد
الدكتوره كمال اسماعيل الله يرحمه واحد
مصري اصلا توفى قبل هذا هو التسعه الاولى
لكنه من باب مفترسات الملك فهد
في اخرين
حاولوا لغواصه الامر
يعني انا ترى لو احد منهم ما اعرفهم شخصا
شخصا لكن انا اعتقد في نفسي اني اكبر
زعلت بعض الاحيان بس بدون ما اسميهم زعلت
لانه
انا ما سالت انا ما طلبت
انا ما طلبت اصلا ولا طلعت اني اقول انا
كلي
وارسلها للمكتب الاستشاري اخر الليل
الساعه 4:00 في الليل
عشان اقوم الساعه 2:00 12 واروح لهم
القاهم مجهزينه لاشياء قل لي خط
صحيح ما دخلت في الزخرفه لكن منطقه
الزخرفه محدده انا
الاقواس انا محددها كل شيء انا حددته
والمطار
وتوسعه المدينه
الميكانيكا الالكتروني
معلومه قديمه صحيحه انا ما بقول انه
كذابين
دكاتره سعوديين لكن كنت انا مسورات
في الفتره اللي يمتسال عنها الشعر كان معي
الفاضل معاي
هذا دور لاي معماري تعرفه الحين تقول يقول
لك مثلا
وما هو يعني ما اقدر معك
الحقيقه لانهم اثقلوا ادخلوا ناس كثير من
السعوديه في التشويه السمعه وما طلعوا
بشيء هم للاسف ما طلع الا بشوات
[موسيقى]
بعدين يا مرته
وحطيت انا ما حطيت لهم ترى
حطيتها
حمايه للمسجد الحرام وجهود الدوله انها
تدخل في الكلام الفاضي هذا حطيت صور وحطيت
هذا من باب اثبات يمت ورطه
احنا اشتغلنا الشهر هذا
لتكريم الفكره الرئيسيه للملك عبد الله
الله يرحمه وبعدين كملنا ثمانيه اشهر مع
الفريق
العائلي في تطوير هذه كل الفتره التي تشكل
5% من تصميم المشروب بعدين انتهى الفريق
ورجعنا كلنا الجامعه
واستلمت الشركه المنفذه تطوير المشروع
وتطوير التصميم
مع الاستشاري الهندسه حقه بعد شهرين اتصلت
عليه الشركه
قالوا نبغاك تيجي عندنا
شركه بن لادن قالوا تعال كمل شغلك
فانا بعد ال 5% الي انا اساسا حاطه ولكن
معايا مشاركين معي بعدها ال 95
10 سنوات
يعني انك تصمم جزئيه
جدا كيف تدير العمل هذا فالتصاميم دائره
وفي اشياء تروح للموقع للتنفيذ وتستكمل
الاشياء يعني احنا بدانا نصب واحنا عارفين
مواقع الاعمده لكن ما نعرف الشكل النهائي
معاه عندنا فكره عامه كيف تكون الاشياء
لكنك تستمر تحط طبقه وراء طبقه وراء طبقه
وترسل معك وادي ياخذ فتره طويله والحسابات
ساعتها
الدوله
معايا ما في طريقه ثانيه انك تضمن الجوده
وتضمن كل شيء الا همم
وزاره الماليه
اولا يحافظ على الجوده يحافظ على السرعه
ويحافظ على يحافظ على الاموال
ترى عمليه معقده لان هذه فوازير حق الدول
معناته لكل شيء يجيب ثلاثه مناقصات وفي
ناس يفتحون
ما هي تابعه للمنفذ
وزاره الماليه
جيبهم عشان يراجعون على الاشياء ويراجعون
على العطاءات العمليه معقده
وفي مشاري ثاني
قاعده طبعا ما كنت جزء من القرار هذا
كراسي
اتخذ فوق في وزاره الماليه الموضوع هذا
سياسي كبير جدا ماهو ماهو على قد مهندسين
مؤكد انه سالت لهم دراسات
من جهه متاكد من وزاره الماليه
يعني الجنوب كله مكتظ معايا
جديده ما هو منطقه الجنوب معي لانه انت
بتحب الدنيا دي كلها
عمر الجنوب اصلا لا يسمح معي همم اه
ها ها
في اعتقادي انه الشاميه
كانت بعد ما حللوا المواقع مؤكد انا متاكد
وانا مع اني ما شرك متاكد بعد ما حطوا
عوامل كثيره للتحليل وجدوا ان الجهه
الشاميه هي الافضل من ناحيه التنميه
والتطوير والعمق اللي يبغونه لكن لم اكن
جزءا ولا اعتقد احد من المهندسين الصغار
اه كان جزء من القرار والتحديد انا اعتقد
مرتبط فوق جدا همم بوزاره الماليه
مهندسينها يعني ما اعرف لكن متاكد انه كان
امامهم هو افضل موقع همم
ضمن الدايره اللي حولهم ولكنه موقع موفق
جدا وسهله التعامل معه اسهل من المواقع
الثانيه طيب همم يقول لك انه مثلا الان
عندنا الحرم هو اهم مبنى موجود في مدينه
مكه اذا ما هو اهم بناء في منطقه الحجاز
كلها صح الحرام فالك الكره الارضيه كلها
اذا اخذنا انه في هذه المنطقه ليش ما اخذ
طاب في التصميم الطابع الحجازي ليش كان
بعيد عن الهويه
لو توقعت كان جبت لك المخططات المخططات
اللي هي الاسكتشات الرئيسيه
لكل الجزئيه في موضوع الهويه في سكيتش
ومرسوم ومحطوط الدائره الاولى والدائره
الثانيه والدائره الثالثه في كندا دائره
وكيفيه تعاطي الهويه معها
تنشر التحالف هذه اتوقع احد الجاي
يذكروني ارسل لكم ممكن
ارسل لك
رام الرئيس لموضوع الهويه والتعاطي مع
الهويه في المنطقه المركزيه همم
الهويه المكيه لا تسمح
لا تسمح معالجاتها
لان هي نتائج
النقطه المهمه الهويه الملكيه نتائج
للمباني السكنيه
وليس نتائج للمباني الرسميه يعني ما عندنا
مثلا
مسجد قرطبه في مكه
ولا عندنا اي مفردات في مدينه مكه تستطيع
من خلالها استجلاب لغه معماريه رسميه
بينما تستطيع انك تشتدلب منها لغه معماريه
تناسب
بناء اقل رسميا من الحرب خلاص فموضوع
الهويه المكيه ورواشينها والكاسكيدان هذا
لمبنى الحرم لازم تستعدوا خلاص
لانه ما في عندي لغه رسميه عندي ارث
لمبابان الحرم في لغه جديده اسسها قديمه
جدا من ايام التوسعه الملك عبد العزيز
وتوسعه الملك سعود وتوسعه
حتى
توسعه الملك فهد
انت ما تقدر تجي ما تقدر تيجي وتقول والله
انا اللغه اللي تاسست في ذاكره الناس ان
هي الحرم المكي خلني الغيها وابدا من
الصفر
وبسوي اجيب لغه التلفزيون
ولا اجيب لك لغه تقول زها حديد ابشرك حديد
ما سويت مقترح مكه لاوريك اياها
عندي الحمد لله الملكه اني اغير اللغه
المعماريه حسب الموقع انا لي لغه معماريه
ويعرفونها كل من يعرفني في مستوى
منهجيه الحل واستراتيجيات الحل نعم
لكن من استراتيجيه استراتيجيات الحل
المعماري عندي انه لكل مقام مقال
اما انه لغتي وخطوطي الخارجي هي لغه هي
مسجد هي نفس اللي مسويها ااه
كوفي شوب هي اللي نفسه اللي مسويها مطار
العراق
ما بدنا المكتبه الملك فهد همم حلقتنا
اللي في مكه يعني
لغتها مختلفه مع انه المبنى كان
تكاليف بسيطه جدا وحاولنا على حجمه كبير
انها ب 30 مليون ايش نخلص
يعني ما نقدر نحط مواد فاخر
الكليات اللي سويتها
ليست متطابقه معه مع بعض
دخل فيها قال هذه حرام همم لكن
فالحرم
كنا
مربوطين بالهويه بالحويه السابقه ولكن
مهنيين زينه جديد
ترجمتها رسمي يعني مبنى
مبنى موهوب ماهو
خصوصيه الرسميه
تحس في المهابه والرسميه والفورمه التي
همم
الافضل انه هي اللغه المؤسسه في السابق هي
اللغه من العماره المملوكيه معي همم في
اللغه العماره الملكيه متطوره
واخدت لان السابقين اللي اشتغلوا في الحرم
في التوسعه الاولى والثانيه معظمه مهندسين
مصريين فقدوا اللغه لكن لكنهم اخذوها
مع تصرف كثير افقدها نقاوتها معايا
يعني معماريا
يعني ما تاخذ كلامي انا اخذ كلام
المعماريه كلهم لا تختفي انها تكون
من العماره اللي اسميها انا نبيله
حماره جميله لكن ليست فاخره وليست نقيه
فيها تشوهات وفيها وفيها اجتهادات شخصيه
افقدتها
فما كنا نبغى نسقط في معمعه الاخطاء
السابقه
فنقينا اللغه القديمه
فورمال فورمال اركي تاكشر من عماره
العماره المملوكيه في اساسها منع سنه
التشوهات عنها وحسننا نسبها وطريقه
تنفيذها
مهم للطلاب العاديين الحقيقه اذا بتقارن
الانجازات
في مشروع التوسعه على المطار
الانجاز فين الانجاز في النقاوه
في الدهشه شوف العماره
طبعا سويت محاضره قبل مده في المدينه
واقول لهم الوظيفه الرئيسيه
للعماره هي صناعه الدهشه
فيكم
مستجده تفهمها الناس وانا اقول العماره
صناعه الدهشه
حماره لا تصل لا تصيبك بالدهشه ليست عماره
المبنى على شكل
شكل ايس كريم
فاكر
اني ما تحقق القداش شيلات تحقق لي
الاستغباء انك تسوي
بصنعاء ثانيه هذه غباء
لكن الدهشه مصدرها انك تدخل في الفراغ
المقاس حقه المواد المستخدمه
رونقها وهدوءها اقدر افهمه واقدر ايش
استمتعه واسرح معه الصراحه الصراحه هذا هو
الدهشه الدهشه مو واحد تسرقه لا الدهشه
مسطره انك تشرح فيها
وكذلك الشكل معك الحرام خش انا ما ادري
وين رحت بس
لكن الحرم الثالث
وتوسعه المدينه ان شاء الله اذا كتاب
متوقفه ومالي
المدينه هذه الفراغ حقها المصلى الواحد
كل مصلي 24 متر في 24 متر في 24 متر وحده
كامله اصلا لحاله وفي كل شيء فيه
سبحان الله نشتغل في المدينه نشتغل بمكه
واذا جينا في المدينه تتحسن الفكره
الفكره اللي في المدينه ان شاء الله اذا
استكمل تحقق نفس افكار مكه ولكن على دهشه
عظمه همم
باوصل فيه اقول لك بس عشان تفهمون ما حقك
من انجاز في مكه في توسعه الثالثه لمكه
والتوسعه المطار عليك بالمقارنه الانسان
العادي عليه بالمقارنه اذا كان يعرف عندك
توسعه المشعه
وعندك توسعه الملك فهد
هذه ما لي علاقه
فيها لكن
المساء مع انه خط واحد بسيط
ولا يصيبك ولا بحاجه ولا يحقق ولا شيء
يعني
حرام
لكن ليس من العماره نهائيا ما هي من
العماره النهائيه
ما يصنف علميا هو مبنى منكم كويس
لكن لن تستطيع ان تجده في كتاب معماري
توسعه الملك فهد مع انها جيده في زمان
وهذه لا لكن تشوها اللغه المعماريه فيها
والاجتهادات
اجتهادات اللي ما كانت معماريه دحين خلي
الواحد يجي واحد يربطني التوسع التوسعه
مهمه خدمه المسلمين لكن كلغه معماريه
لم تحقق شيئا كثير نحو هويه نحو نحو دهجه
تمر فيها ما تدري عنها اصلا لكن التوسعه
الثالثه
كله فراغ فيها يصيبك بالدهشه
والدور الارض
وتنطلق من من المصاطب لن توصل الكعبه وانت
في دهشه متكرره مع
مبنى المطار في دهشه متكرره ربطنا احنا
الهدفين ما يغيب عنا الهدف انه نبغى نجذب
الناس للمبنى عشان يطوفي من الصحن عشان
الكبار
لكن حققت ان النتيجه انك وانت تسحب وسط
المبنى اصبح المبنى جزء من الصحن هذا
السبب انه فتحنا الواجهه فخم جدا
اننا
ينافس الصحن قدر ما نقدر نخليه هنا
الرئيسيه لان الصحن هو الصحن ما حد يقدر
يزيد لكتابته
واقدم الناس بالمبنى يجب انه المبنى منافس
للصحه يجب ان الف الصلاه
اهم شغله نعالجه
حيد التعامل غير عميق مع الواجهه هذه وفهم
المشكله حتى انا حاره الفكره والمليارات
اللي صبت معاي ممكن كنا نخطي ونيجي نسوي
اي حركات عبديه في الوادي النتيجه انك
قصدنا قفلته الواجهه لو قفلت الواجهه
يطوفون لانهم والله
شعرهم جزء من الصح كل واحد يقول لك مع
السلامه
هذه في الدائره الاولى اللغه الرسميه
جرام عباره عن دوائر
الدائره الثانيه
الدائره الثالثه ولا الثانيه ما ادري انا
عشان لا تذكرني عشان اتذكر التفاصيل لكن
لما جيت الهويه المكيه في الدائره الثالثه
دائره كامله تجد انها بين بين 300 يعني
المركز الكعبه بين 300 متر وتجد الى 300
الى الى 600 هذه الدائره هذه الهويه
المكيه
اعاده صياغه الهويه المكيه لكن سياقتها
بطريقه عقلانيه ماهو بطريقه عبثيه صياغتها
كالعاتي حنا نبغى حضر ضخم جدا من الحمامات
والمواضي
خلاص
20,000 ميضه 12000 حبه
ارقام مخيفه
الطلب
اكبر حمامات على وجه الكره
السؤال كيفيه التوظيف
التوظيف لازم نخلي المبنى هذا يتابع لازم
نخليهم متعه لازم نخليه ماهو حمامات
الحمامات تصير ثانويه في الهرجه
فقلنا الباكيجن الباكيجن اللي كيف نغلف
العمليات هذه كلها حنا عندنا اكثر اذا ما
خانتني الذاكره
عشان نحقق الارقام هذه حوالي خمسه كيلو
متر طولي من من من
الاشياء عشان خدم الناس لها
[موسيقى]
لا قلنا نحيها ونخلي حركه الناس هي مصدر
الامن للمكان
نسوي اختراق نقلب اللعبه خلاص
مستقل بدايه عشان تشغيله صيانات اوسطه
عشان هذه من ناحيه اداره وتشغيله الوحده
لكن عشان تواصلها ما بين الحرم طالع من
الحرم مشيت في الجسور وجئت المنطقه هذه
ومشيتها للشباب
واحد يبغى ياكل يطلع الاكل واحد يبغى ما
ادري عرف اللي يشتري مسابح العالم كنا
طورنا الهرجه
كنا حنا بنحط
ما ابغى اسوي دكان عميق كبير
صاحب شركه صغيره
الحمامات وهذا الشارع فيجي في هذا المنطقه
يسويها المحلات الثانيه معي وانت ماشي معي
ونبغاك ما تقدر تدخل المحل ليش ليش ما
تدخل المحل ابغاك من برا وانت واقف معايا
علشان اعيد لك هلا الصوره الذهنيه للشوارع
التجاريه حق مكه لما الواحد فاكر زمان
نوقف
ويعطيك وانت واقف بيصير انت خلقت لك
خمسه كيلو متر من الدكاكين اللي احيانا
الناس
وخدامنا الحرم وقعدنا الصوره الذهنيه لمكه
وافتكينا من شر
انه منطقه
وبعدين تدخل في كيف تخدمها وكيف توصل لهم
الخدمات يعني خلقنا 5 كيلو متر من الشوارع
التجاريه اللي تعيده هويه مكه وجينا في
الواجهات حقه هذه حطينا مشربيات
وجينا
العماره
مكه
وكل المباني
لكن بدل ما تتفرج في وانت واقف بتشوف لك
كيلو لا اسوي لك زي المنحنى واكسره فما
تشوفه كله دائما يتفتم لكن
امور السلامه والحشود هذه برضه في الجزئيه
وما بين المصائب هذا اكثر اللي ما حط عليه
ولا احد ينتبه له اكثر تعقيدا واكبر عمقد
من التوسعه نفسها
والدروس المعماريه فيه والدروس المعماريه
والعمرانيه في
من الدروس الشيء الكثير والناس ميداليه
عنها اصلا يمكن عشان سبب انه ما انتهى
ويستخدم كامل لكن فيه من الدروس العمرانيه
المعماريه والعمرانيه الكبيره وهذا يجيب
لك انه لغه اسلاميه فورمل للمبنى الرسمي
معي ولغه
العماره المكيه عندما جاءت الفرصه
لتوظيفها لكن ما نوظفها عميانيه
وهذا الفرق بين ان الواحد لما اقول لك
واحده الاستراتيجيات انه لكل مقام مقال
تعال تعال
اقول لك والله
العماره الملكيه القديمه اوكي يعني
كاسر رسميا يجي واحد يقول لك الحرم
المساجد لازم تكون همم
كان افهمك تقول لي على ميسي في الحاره على
حاجه لكن مسجد حرم قبله المسلمين
يجب ان يكون فيه درجه من الرسميه اي عبثيه
في التنظيف في موضوع انه والله المباني
القديمه
الفلاني اللي خورستان ولا مدري ايش اسم
المناطق دي ولا في المغرب قديمه
الحرم
توسعه الثالثه هو ده المختصر والمضاف
والنصاطب والشاحنات تمثل ذروه العماره في
اي في اي اطار الدنيا كلها
الا اربع المباني المصاطب
طبعا حق المدينه حق المدينه
في حوالي 75 متر في 75 متر في ارتفاع 36
متر فخم بس انه مختلف
لكن في دروس كثيره في مكه
في خطوط معينه في مبنى المصادر في النخل
يحدد لك الاسكاي لا خط الافق للحرم وفي
مناطق مشجره وفي طورنا ان كان ضمن عملنا
من الساحات صورنا المعابر هذه اللي اول
اتكلم لك الشرايين طريقه ابراهيم الخليل
وطريق في منظومه الجسور وتشجير وما تشجير
كامله عندي موجوده
وارسلتها على الحقيقه ارسلتها انا من باب
الامانه لان افكار عامه ارسلتها لكل
المهتمين هذا الموضوع الثاني لكن لا لا
موجود في تركيبنا من الاساس انه في منظومه
التشكيل
وقتها يمكن تتكلم لسه ما بنيت واليوم
موجوده لكن وحده لشركه تقولها برضه ان
الباب رغم ضخامته طبعا هو اضخم باب يعني
في العالم لانه يدف بيد واحده يعني عائله
يمكن 20 واحد
وفي ناس زعلوا عليه همم يقول لك
انا انا انا قد استعدت من الشركه فانا
مواطن الان والمواطن انا زي زي اي مواطن
ثاني يعلق يعلق يعلق يعلق شيء
ولكن شفت الباب
هو الباب هذا
اله
معقده
اله مطوره جدا
اقدر احط لك جهاز همم يحسب الحشود احنا
مركبينها من زمان للحياه الدنيا هذه
حساس
ويشتغل اهاليه كل شيء يشتغل عليه بكنترول
عالي بشيء لكن تفترض دائما في سيناريو وبي
سي ما ما اشتغلت الهالات ولا ما اشتغلت
هذه فانت تفتح بيتكم بيتك نعم
فكانت من الاشتراكات انه يفتح باليد نهايه
واحد شخص يدفه
موجود الحقيقه انه يشتغل بطريقه جدا
الفيديو ده اللي منتشر
والناس جالسه تنشره تشعر في كل محل يمكن
في الكره الارضيه كلها
انا زعلت الحقيقه لانه الناس جالسه تنشر
شيء اولا
مهم انها تعكس الصوره
متصوره
البحر
كيف ارد على واحد فرحان على خطا هو متصور
انه من ضخامه وعشره انفار ومدري
ايش الاحتمالات الثلاثه انه بقى في وضع
كده مشكله
كنت ضخمه حتعيكم
التركي
يا اخواني ترى الموضوع
كده في ناس
شو في عندهم يعني زايده مفرطه يعني
اكثر من اللازم حساسيه
ما هم مضبوط الان يتعدل وفعلا دحين يعني
يعدلونه اعتقد انه
معدلهم حساسيه شويه
يعني سمو ولي العهد
مقابله مع بي بي سي نور بي بي سي
ام بي سي او حاجه
القواعد الرئيسيه للناس وحريه الناس في
النقاش هذه
وانا وانا عندي قواعد كمان اكثر تعقيداولي
هو تكلم انه الدين
واقول كلام ما قال ولي العهد قديم
حاضر قدر الامكان ان شاء الله ما اعتقد
النتيجه بس اولا انا لا امش ولا اسمع في
النقاش معي شيء يمص قدسيه الدين
والقدسيه
في محلها
الحكم ما اسمها احد يتكلم فيه ليه لانه هو
الضامن الوحيد لنا شوف العالم حوالينا كيف
الناس
رهيبه الحكم
موضوع التخوف وما خوف ضروره ليا ولابنائي
ولا انا كلنا كمجتمع انه هيبه الحكم ما حد
يقرب منها ولا غير مسموح تتكلم على هيبه
الحكم ومرتكزاته
ما تسمح بها فانا مسبح من نفسي
القاعده الثالثه البلد
تجيني واحد يتناقش فيها اي
اي نوع من العنصريه
اي شيء بس وحده البلد
باسمك اسم الناس اسماء الناس واعرابها
ولا اسمح بالتعرض لها فلذلك لما دحين اكثر
واحد ينتقد امانه جده انا انا انتقد امانه
جده لا يستحيل وحتى لو في شيء اصدر الامير
ان تجدوك عميد
لكن هو شخص محترم عندي ولا يمكن يتعرضوا
باسمها الشخصيه حتى لوراء لما شغله بوزاره
الاسكان ولا وزاره بلديه هل انت انت اقول
وجهه نظري في القرار ولا في شيء او في
ماذا يفترق لكن هذا تعرب ما اتعرب همم
شخص باسمه هذا القواعد الخمسه اللي عندي
وهي ماشي اعتقد الى حدين كبير وتراني
حركات اجزم اني ملتزم بها يمكن بعض
الاحاديث همم
[موسيقى]
ممكن تصير كده ما ادري لكني لكن هذه قواعد
الحقيقه وانا اعتقد انها مهمه للناس كلهم
وتعرها اذا اذا التزمنا بها كلنا ترى سقف
الحريه واسع جدا في البلد واللي يجيك يقول
لك سقف الحريه في السعوديه ما هو اسف ترى
خبر يعني انا اكتب تغريدات
واحد في البلديه يقول والله العظيم بعض
الاحيان ما لنا شغله الا في الصباح نفوق
ونشوف باقي شو مسويه لنا مشكله
[موسيقى]
البلديه ولا المرور ههه يمكن يمكن يشوف لك
مشروع ينشرون فيه ههه
همم ليش ما يعني مثلا في التوسع كان فيه
مثلا من او يمكن فيه همم اللي هي من
الانظمه لتسيير الحشود بدل ما يكون في
العسكري توزعونه
بتطلع من الارض عشان ترتب بالناس
منظومه الحواجز الذكيه ههه
لكن مخططاتها موجوده
شغال قبل ما امشي همم كنت في بدايه ان
نبدا في التفكير كيف نصنع الحاجز الذكي
موضوع عنك
تتخلص
لكن بدل بدل ما هدفين بدا ما اكثر
ما اعتمد على القرار البشري القابل للخطا
هذا الاثنين اذا حققتهم المنظومه يكون
اكثر اليه
[موسيقى]
ويسيطر لي على الحدود ويوجهها لكن موجود
على استراتيجيه
واضحه
المشروع المعماري
التصميم
للمبنيين معتمد على كيفيه
اداره الحدود
ليس على مبني على استراتيجيه شكله حلو
عندنا المعماريين عندنا سوالف بعض الاحياء
في الاساس في الاساس تحقيق مبنيه
هه وبعدين لما وضعت الحل اللي يحقق هذا
كملنا الاحجيه المعماريه حوله والحجيات
الاخرى الباكيه معه لكن المنطلقات كله هو
كده انا بعطيك البساطه
الاستراتيجيه الاولى
عندك كتله بشريه ضخمه
بدل ما تتعامل مع الكتله البشريه هاه جزء
الكتله البشريه وتعامل مع كل جزء لوحده
منفصل عن بقيه العيسى
العمل بدل ما يتعامل مثلا بعطيك ارقام بس
من راسي بدل ما يتعاملوا مع مليون اجزائها
الى 10 اقسام يصير رجال الامن يتعامله مع
100,000 او 100 الفين ومئه الفين و100,000
تشرد السيطره هذه اول استراتيجيه التوسعه
السعوديه الثانيه وتوسعه المطار وتوسعه
المديح مبنيه يا فتاح يا عليم على القولون
على تطبيق هذه الاشتراكيه التجزئه
دي فائده المبدا الانجليزي الانجليزي
احجيه طويله جدا عشان اشرحها كامله معك
وانا اتمنى اتمنى انه من يديره
ما ادري انه يكون فاهم الاحتلال كامله
اشكاليه اذا كان
لانه بعض الاحيان تنطلق مع الوقت ها الشيء
ينسى معي الاديان تبدا مع الوقت تلقاها
تنسى تدخل فيها امور اخرى معك حتى الافكار
تبدا بعدين مع تراكم متغير اليد واختفى كل
المشروع
ذاكره المشروع اذا غابت ذاكره المشروع
يجون الناس ما هم فاهم الموضوع معه بطريقه
لكن بعطيك مثلا واحد
شو مبنى المطار هذا
اول شيء ليس مطاف واحد
سته مطافات مستقله عن بعض
واحد
سته مطافات مستقله
عندك الصحن
وعندك في محل في دور معين
يعني انا حاطه مدري حلو ولا ما حد فاهم
لانه ما اشوفه يستخدم وفي الدور الارضي
وفي الدور الاول وفي
يسمونه ميزانيه الدوره الاول وفي السطح
وفي ميزانين السطح سته
يعني مدخلوا الناس تدخل تصل اليه
يسوون الطواف
يصلون ركعتين الطواف يدخلون المسعى يخلصون
راجعون خلصنا
تيجي في المطاف نفسه هذه الاستراتيجيه
الاولى قسمناهم الى مطافات مستقله يعني لو
صار شيء في اي مطار هذا الطرف الثاني اصلا
ما تدري انه صار شيء ورجال الامن يقتلون
يسيطروا على الحل ويحلوها المشكله خلاص
صار مشكله مثلا في مطافي الدوره العاديه
الاول الدور الاول
وهذا يبغى لها تركيز وان شاء الله تفهمني
مسطح البناء
كنت في محروقات سابقه ان المبنى المبنى
لم يكن مصمم للطواف لكم لانه ما كان عندهم
مشاكل
خمسه متر ما ادري عشره متر مجلوك معي
الحين نبغى نسوي المطار ما لم يعد للمصلي
الهدف لمحه عشان يكون مصلح
لكن هو في الاساس في وقت الذروه يكون
مطافي
البحر حقه البحر حطيناكم 25 هو 35 25
وعشره متر
الاول
سمع كده ترجمه ترجمه من صحيح منطقه الملجا
ان الناس تلجا لها
القاعده كالعاده
عند الحشود سير اذا زاد
الكثافه عن رقم معين تبدا يصير التداول
ويسير الموت
اذا ارتفعت الكثافه
انه رجال الامن يفرقون
المطارخ وتسحب الناس وتوقف لحد يدخل
المسجد
اذا ما تقدر اسميه انا اذا ما تقدر تخفف
الطلب همم
زود الصبلاي زود المساحه المعطاه على طول
خفض ايش الكتابه المنطقه الثانيه بينه
وبين المنطقه الاساسيه هذه
الحواجز الذكيه
لما يصير التداكم
الناس اللي تموت من ايش تموت انه القفص
الصدري يسمونه
ان الحواجز هذه اذا جاء الضغط
لرقم معين تنفتح
قواعد التصميم لكن خلاص خلاص
جنوبيه هل السبب ايه زاد الاعداد وما في
تفريخ ماتت الناس 100 مدري 200 نفر ما هذا
الشبابيك واحنا ما نبغاها تصير احنا لا
نرفض مبدا انها تصير ما في واحد يجي يقول
لك لا لا ما حد سيل لا يا ابني انت افترض
انها صارت افترض الاسواق
احنا حطينا الحل هذا لازم بس 10 ميت منطقه
يجلس فيها مين
تكون فاضي يا رجال رجال
الصحه
يعني اي خدمات خفيفه جدا
ولكنها جاهزه
ومتى كمان تصير حلاوتها ذلحين افترضى
السيناري وانك في الدروه وانه 25 دقيقه
الناس يحتاجون فراغ اكبر لانه الصلاه
تحتاج فراغ اكثر من الطواف واعداد ان
الناس في الفراغ هذا اكثر همم من ما
تستوعبه الصلاه فتحتاج فراغ اخر وتفتح هذه
وقت الصلاه الناس تتخلخل الكثافه
يصلون وهم مرتاحين يطلعوا يكملوا مشواره
ما اقدر ما في انسان
اي واحد الان ما هو فاهم كيف التصرف معه
فاهم كيف بني المشروع وكيف الاستثمارات
بالمليارات مبنيه على الاستراتيجيه
الاستراتيجيات معينه يجي واحد مو فاهم
حاجه
لو برنامج
30 مليون 30
مليون في الحج لانه اصلا مشكلتك في همم
الامارات
يكفي يمكن شتيمه اليوم هو بالحسابات
الحسابات الرسمي طبعا ما تفتح للعمره تقول
والله بفتح العمره في شهر واحد
يعني اذا كان العمره
منتشره على على الاشهر كلها ما عدا الحج
الاستثناء ولا حاجه
طيب ما قبل التوسعه كم بيكون يكفي
الارقام
لكن عشان اعلمك بس انا لازم ادخل واحسب لك
اياها في عامل الزمن
انا ما بدخل في الارقام الدقيقه لكن قول
الان المطار
ترى
لانه اللي موجود يكفي اكثر من اللازم معي
الان يخدم حوالي مليون ونص معك مشكلتك ليس
بالحرام وتوفير الحرام ولا فراغات مشكلتك
في ايصال الناس واخراجهم معايا وكانت جزء
من الخطه
والدوره ان شاء الله همم ماشي في امور
التوصيل اي اي اشكاليه الوحيده
لكن توفيق الفراوله
على قولهم حسبت بدوي في عندي الحسابات لكن
الان ما دام اني ماني مستذكر ابي اسويها
لك حسبه بدويه
100000 في الساعه الان استيعاب المطاف على
اساس انه كله مخده وينه الجسور واصله وان
البوات مسيطر عليها لانه بدون تكمله
استكمال المنظومه بدون الحواجز ما توصل
100,000 معي تصير
فقط لا غير لكن بدون استكمال المنظومه في
100,000
نهايه ما في 100,000 رحنا نتكلم بالمنظوم
الكامله تقدر توصل 100,000 اذا اكتمل
المشروع سنه سنتين معرفه ان شاء الله قريب
باذن واحد باذن واحد احد حتصير المنظومات
تستوعب هي 107 لكن قول 100,000
في 24
اليوم في 24 ساعه كم
اسوي لك
اربعه مليون
عندك مليون
اليوم الواحد مليون 30 مليون نقلتهم
اقدمهم في شهر واحد
فما بالك لو لو
نشرتم على مدى سنه
متكامل
مسافه طويله للقطار
انا انا الحقيقه عندي
انا من الناس اللي
وحبه دائما
تطوير النفسيه القديمه حتى العشوائي حتى
الشعب يحبوه كذا لانه يعطي فرصه لخلط بيئه
وانسنه معايا
انا الحقيقه عشان بس لا اظلم واحد انا لا
اعرف
تفاصيل هذا المشروب اعرفه لما كنت في
المخطط العام
وجانك فكره وكان عندي اعتراض عليه
وكتبت في تدريب 27 لكن كان الاعتراض على
معطيات قديمه جدا
يمكن الان المعطيات مختلفه
ولا اذكر 27 في 27 27
قد ما تكون من الذكاء ممكن تكون من الذكاء
انك براءه الذمه
هذه ايش دراني انا لكن لكن الحقيقه انا ما
حبي
حتى تدخلات وتغيير اللغه
احب دائما تطوير اللغه انا ما استفيد شيئا
حقيقه الامر انا عبد الله الثاني لا
استفيد شيئا من اني
محور مصطلح
بينما شرايين مكه الطبيعيه
تحقق لي نفس الاشياء ولكن بشخصيه مستقله
لمكه
لكني اجي
وارسم خط
دون مراعات للجبل لوادي واي شيء امامي
هذه نظريه في ناس ممكن يقول لك يقبلها
ويسويها ويعتبرها ما عندي مشكله
ما يحول مكه الى مدينه
ذات رونك مختلف
الشخصي لن استمتع يمكن عشان معماري
يمكن لن استمتع باني امشي في الطريق اللي
يسمونه مثلا
لكن كان بودي لو انه تبع لانه كان في مسار
هناك للوادي ماشي بطريقه غريبه
انه الطريقه هذه انها طريقه طيبه لكن انا
اشعر بالمستوى الشخصي لا انا احب الش مكه
الطبيعيه
واطورها واخلق بيئه مختلفه نهائيا خاصه
بمكه
وهذا المهم ان ان الصوره الذهنيه للمدينه
المدينه
والعماره
عباره عن صوره ذهنيه انت الان اذا رحت اي
مدينه ما اعرف روح لك مدينه
انت ايش اللي بقي لك من زيارته هي الصوره
الذهنيه اللي جربتها نعم صح ولا لا وهي
الرساله كل بعض الاحيان بتروح المدينه
تقول
ليتني والله ما رحت له واستخدمت لك كلمتين
في في تدميرها صح وبعض المدن تتكلم به
عنها بطريقه عاطفيه صح ولا لا
المدينه كذلك
انا
في مكه
يهموني الحقيقه لكن يهمني في الاساس مخزون
العالم الاسلامي هذا الثلاثين الثلاثين
مليون اللي بيجون هذولاء كل سنه عندي 30
مليون هاه جهاز ارسال جهاز ارسال
كل الصوره الذهنيه اللي يشوفونها في مكه
كل ما كانت خاصه بمكه مختلفه في مكه كل ما
كان التجربتهم مختلفه وكان نقلهم مختلف
لكن لما اجيب لهم يحطهم في المسار هذا
الصوره الذهنيه اللي حيطلعوا بها كانك في
دبي
يختلف ولا شيء لكن لا توجد فيها الصوره
الذهنيه الصوره الذهنيه في الحرم مختلفه
واحد يدخل التوسعه والمطر ينسى الصوره
الذهنيه يستحيل واحد اذا اكتمل ان شاء
الله يدخل مبنى المصادر وينسى الصوره
الذهنيه
يستحيل واحد ياخذ تجربه الصلاه والخروج في
الساحات والدخول في المناطق التجاريه اللي
احنا خلقناها عاديه خمسه كيلو معه وريحه
ان شاء الله الناس
حاضر روايه الريحه
جزء من الصوره الذهنيه اللي في مخيلتك
نظرك كل الحواس حاولنا نفعلها في ما كان
تحت سيطرتنا في الماضي انا اتمنى انه مكه
انه يصير التعامل معها في كل شيء في جميع
الحواشي
تعرف انه مكه
ممكن تستغربونا عليها
طب الحرام انا في حديقه مستمره
والله العظيم حتى بخشه اللي عندنا طوليه
كده في واحد كان الله يرحمه
عم عبد المعين
كانت اداره صح
البقشه كله بخشه فيها واحد بعياله
حقته معنا
جوه المهندسين شاف قصه الخواجه يقول بفورد
والله الحديقه هذه لزوم ليه يا ابوي
السياره
مكه كلها
والله العظيم ما حد يصدق الكلام هذا لا
وبعدين
صناعيه ويحط لي لعبه حق اولاد اطفال ويقول
لك والله حاسبها عنده يقول عندنا 100
حديقه المهم 100 حديقه مكه
بنت تخيل بس الحياه بس القصه هذه
كانت مكه
[موسيقى]
والهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز
وضياء الدين المدني التصوير احمد ابو شعر
وساعده فواز البرجه والتحرير جميل عبد
الاحد عبد المجيد العطاس فيها التلوين
وساعد في الانتاج
هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه الماليه للنشر
والتوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج من مدينه الرياض
اسماء المقبل